chile se enfrenta a una de las
elecciones más cruciales de su historia
el próximo presidente tendrá que
enfrentarse a grandes retos entre ellos
la inflación disparada el sistema de
pensiones descapitalizado y una
desigualdad exacerbada tras la pandemia
en la que se permitieron tres retiros
anticipados del 10 por ciento de los
fondos un obstáculo el haber perdido 50
mil millones de dólares que mariachi les
mucha plata
del ahorro previsional y esa plata se ha
liberalizado en algo que uno llama el
consejo los críticos al neoliberalismo
están haciendo neoliberalismo cuando
dicen yo quiero mi plata yo la manejo
a pesar de que esto alivió la situación
económica momentáneamente un porcentaje
de la población ha quedado sin fondos
para jubilarse el nuevo mandatario
también está llamado a llevar a cabo la
transición entre dos regímenes
constitucionales con la redacción de la
nueva carta magna es el gobierno que
viene va a ser el verdadero gobierno de
la transición en chile- y probablemente
uno de los icónicos estarías chiles va a
ser es porque yo creo que este realmente
va a poner término al legado de la
dictadura el gobierno que viene yo creo
que va a tener que tener esa dualidad si
va a ser un gobierno transicional y va a
tener que favorecer los cambios no puede
con motivos usarse en esperar el nuevo
texto y no a realizar las
transformaciones que se están esperando
con tanta urgencia sin embargo el punto
de quiebre de chile se remonta al 2019
cuando estallaron las protestas sociales
más graves desde la dictadura por lo que
desde el 18 de octubre de este año se
empezó a redactar la nueva constitución
con el propósito de hacer de chile un
país más inclusivo moderno estable y
seguro
la expectativa es ver si el nuevo
gobernante se adapta a este nuevo modelo
que los chilenos esperan